well
you're uh somebody one of the most uh
respected uh famous scientists in the
world sitting on the farm gazing up at
the stars
so you seem like an appropriate person
to ask the completely inappropriate
question of
what do you think is the meaning of it
all what's the meaning of life
that's an excellent question and if we
ever find an alien that we can converse
with
i would like to answer this i would like
to ask for an answer to this question
because
um would they have a different opinion
you think well they might be wiser
because they looked around for a while
but
i'm afraid they will they will be silent
i'm afraid they will not have a good
answer and
i think uh it's
it's the process that you should get
uh satisfied by the process of learning
you should enjoy okay so it's not so
much
that there is a meaning i in fact there
is
as far as i can tell things just exist
you know
uh and it's um i think it's
inappropriate for us to assign
a meaning for our existence because you
know we
as a civilization we will eventually
perish you know and uh
nothing will be you know just another
planet on which life died you know and
if you look at the big scheme of things
who cares like who cares and how can we
assign significance to what we are doing
you know so
if you say the meaning of life is this
well
it will not be around in a billion years
so what you know it cannot be the
meaning of
life because life you know nothing will
be around so
i think we should just enjoy the process
and
you know it's like many other things in
life you enjoy good food
okay and you can enjoy learning
why because it makes you uh
appreciate better where you know the
environment that you live in
and sometimes people think religion for
example
is in conflict with science spirituality
con in conflict that's not true uh
if you see a watch and you look at it
from the outside
you know you might say oh that's
interesting but then if you start to
open it up and learn about how it works
you appreciate it more so science is the
way to learn about how the world works
and it's not in conflict to this
the meaning that you assign to all of
this but it
helps you appreciate the world better so
in fact i would think that a religious
person should
promote science because it gives you a
better appreciation of what's around you
you know it's like you know if you buy
uh in a grocery buy something you know a
bunch of
fruits that are packed together and you
can't
see from the outside exactly what kind
of fruits are inside but if you open it
up and study
you appreciate better the merchandise
that you get right so you pay the same
amount of money but
at least you know what's inside so why
don't we figure out what the world is
about you know what the universe
contains what is the dark matter
it will help us appreciate you know the
bigger picture
and then you can assign your own flavor
to what it means you know i i think
i'm truly grateful that a person like
you exists
at the center of the scientific
community gives me faith and hope about
this uh this big journey that we call
science
so uh thank you for writing the book you
wrote recently
you have many other books and articles
that i think people should definitely
read and thank you for wasting all this
time with me this is truly an honor
thank you so much not a waste at all and
thank you for having me i learned
a lot from your questions and your
remarks thank you thank you
you